Hey, youtubers... This is Charlie
Happy New Year!
So, I wanted to start of 2016 right
This is going to be like a crazy Star Wars theory video,
so just careful for spoilers if you have not seen The Force Awakens yet.
We're just going to be talking about some very specific things.
There is a new round of the giveaway, too.
It's two IMAX gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
So here we go.  10 crazy theories
about Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
Starting with one of the biggest ones: Darth Jar Jar
So you know of course
going into the movie, this was one of the bigger theories,
but coming out of the movie, it seemed
like everybody thought that Snoke was going to be someone else.
I think the reason that it caught so much fire is because
1) You know, it just sounded so ridiculous that it was amazing,
and it overshadowed everything the emperor was doing
in the original trilogy.
If you have no idea what the theory is,
it's exactly what it sounds like.
It just states that Jar Jar Binks was a Sith Lord THE WHOLE TIME!!!
So all of the buffoonery, which was part of his act
to deceive the Jedi (grammar?)
Anakin Skywalker turns to the dark side,
The Empire takes over.
Everything in that theory states that Darth Jar Jar
was behind it all.  So of course, it's pretty fantastical
and therefore, probably not true :(
But, like I said, the most damning evidence against it
is the next big theory that Supreme Leader Snoke,
who predates the Emperor is secretly Darth Plagueis (holy shit),
the person that Palpatine referenced to Anakin Skywalker
as being the Sith Lord that found a way to cheat death.
Now the thing about this is that it's slightly more likely
than the Darth Jar Jar theory, but I also don't think it's true
because J. J. Abrams for the most part
he didn't throw out the prequel material,
but he also kind of said he "stepped around" them
when mining material for Episode VII.
Abrams kind of described Episode VII as like a love letter to Episodes IV and V,
while laying the groundwork for this new trilogy.
you know for, for future filmmakers in Episodes VIII and IX
to do completely new things.
So while he didn't take a dump on the prequels,
he, you know, he also said that he really didn't
do anything from the prequels.
So Plagueis for me is just kind of like expanded universe material
where it's like, you know, it's very interesting to read about, but I don't think that it's going to have a lot
of influence over what's going on in the new trilogy.
Now if you go back and rewatch Episode VII,
there is a music cue for Supreme Leader Snoke's scenes that's very similar to the Darth Plagueis
scene from Episode III, so, you know, you could say
well oh they're trying to mirror this,
but I really think it's just meant to mirror Emperor Palpatine with Supreme Leader Snoke
like they're both the big villains of those trilogies.
So Snoke is like the "Palpatine" of the new trilogy,
but that doesn't necessarily apply any kind of relationship.
Which leads me to my next big theory:
The Sith are completely gone in the new trilogy,
and they have been supplanted by the Knights of Ren
as the evil organization that uses the force.
Now this is where we're getting into the books based on the new trilogy.
Now there is a novelization of the movie that includes
a whole lot of details that just didn't make it into the movie:
things they cut out, scenes that they didn't end up shooting,
but they're all canon.  There is a cross sections book
that does breakdowns of a lot of the characters.
Kylo Ren has a really bad relationship with his father
who doesn't live up to all the standards that he heard about
during the rebellion against The Empire,
so naturally, like all emo teens, he seeks a new father
figure, which is where Snoke comes in,
helps to turn him to the dark side.
Eventually, Kylo Ren ascends to the Knights of Ren
and kills the rest of the Jedi at Luke Skywalker's new academy.
That's really what this scene is right here,
like the moment that he kills all those other people.
Based on what the books say, the reason that Snoke is
so interested in Kylo Ren is because he's a fallen Jedi
from the light side.  It feels like he could be a more powerful force user
because he can harness both the dark and the light.
Now there is some expanded universe material that
gets into this with Jacen Solo's character,
but remember, expanded universe has absolutely
nothing to do with this new trilogy.
But the idea is still there, so it seems like J. J. Abrams
was trying to push into new territory in his interpretation
of the force without really getting into the minutiae in
a bad way like midi-chlorians or trying to over-explain
things.  Really he's kinda laying groundwork for Ryan Johnson
and future filmmakers to spell it out a little bit more.
So I think what Abrams did is like, he just didn't want to
shackle all the future filmmakers that would ever end up
making films about Star Wars with Lucas' ideas
so he just kind of laid the groundwork for a lot of new
things to come in.  So it's like, well you know, the force is very complicated,
in a knowable and really broad way, so of course
there would be different types of religions that would rise up around it.
Like we have the church of the force, which is a bunch
of non-force users that really believe in Jedi ideals,
and then we have the Knights of Ren, which is kind of
like the new Sith organization.
Next big theory: this is a fun one, especially if you're
a big Tumblr user.  Poe Dameron is a gay character.
Not the first gay character to ever come into the
Star Wars Universe, but one of the first ones that we've seen onscreen.
The reason that people think this is because of that
scene where he and Finn are reunited, and he like bites
his lip and looks at him.  There are whole new orders of
religion rising up around this in the Tumblr universe,
and all I'll say is that probably what ended up happening
when they were filming this scene is Oscar Isaac just,
you know, (?) he was just having some fun with the character,
and they didn't really spell out whether or not he's gay
before the movie started.  So really all you can say is
that he is not not gay.  So if you're one of those people
that really does want him to be a gay character,
then you can always point to this scene and be like,
"Well even if it wasn't on the page, there is truth in the moment,
so Oscar Isaac was subconsciously making him a
gay character," but if you also, if you don't want him
to be gay, you also point to Oscar Isaac just messing
around on the day, just just having some fun with the character
and not really intending for Poe to be gay in the literal sense.
Next big theory: Luke Skywalker activated R2 at the end
of the movie.  That's why he didn't wake up 'til the end
to show them the rest of the map.  Now I love the idea
that while Luke Skywalker has been missing in the galaxy,
he's been communing with the force, getting more
powerful, you know, just like Obi-Wan was when he was
when he was waiting for Luke to grow up, but J. J. Abrams
has already explained that R2 was woken up by BB-8
when he rolled up with his piece of the map, and that's
why R2 didn't wake up until the end of the movie.
Next big theory: the new Star Wars prequels are going to
reignite the Mandalorian canon.  Now, if you remeber Boba Fett
from the original trilogy, he wore Mandalorian armor,
but then in the prequels, George Lucas created the
Jango Fett character, and that spawned the clone army
and took everything in this sideways direction.
Now, the Mandalorians are this ancient warrior race that
did end up dying out.  They kinda deal with it during the
Great Sith War comic book, the Dark Wars comic book,
so you should definitely check that out.  It's much
grander, much more awesome story than anything that
the prequels dealt with.  Maybe the new movies are
going to course correct that a little bit, and there's
always gonna be the clones.  They're not gonna
REDCON that from the prequels.  There, there's even the
joke where it's like, "Maybe we should start using a clone
army, General Hux."  My conditioning is perfect, and that
argument, just we can get the clone wars.
When Han Solo is walking them up to Maz Kanata's
pirate castle, there is a Mandalorian banner waving at
the top.  So Mandalorians do exist in this universe.
They might still be alive.  They might all be extinct. Who knows?
But that is something for Ryan Johnson to explore or
the expanded universe.  A lot of things will probably be
dealt with in the novels that don't make it into the movie.
Next big theory: this is going back to Star Wars: Rogue One
which is coming out next Christmas.  Alan Tudyk's
character is secretly a young version of Lor San Tekka,
the person at the beginning of Episode VII played by
Max von Sydow who is very old.  The age is about right.
He would've been alive during the original trilogy, and
Rogue One is all about the mission to steal the plans for
the first Death Star.  So even though that movie's a
spin-off, it's mostly going to deal with things happening
in that time.  They're going to have to link it to present
day with some characters, you know, meaning that there
there are gonna have to be old characters like Leia's age,
people that were alive that are also in that movie.
So it stands to reason that one of these characters in
the spin-off will appear in the anthology films as a much
older version of themselves in present day.
Next big theory: How did Maz Kanata get her hands on
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber, and why had she been
holding onto it for so long without trying to tell Luke
Skywalker, or give it back to him, or give it to Leia for that matter.
Well I'm guessing it didn't pass into her possession 'til
sometime after Luke Skywalker disappeared, so giving
it back to him directly wasn't an option,
and we do know that she is force sensitive, like she can
sense the force in Rey.  That was kinda what that line
was about where she's like, "I'm no Jedi, but I understand the force."
So this is where, even though we've thrown out the
expanded universe, there are some similar elements to
things that happen in the expanded universe.
So what happens is, is during the Thrawn trilogy, there
is a Luke Skywalker clone that is using Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber,
so what we find out is that the Emperor has this secret
facility, like an underground vault where he keeps his
most precious items, and in that vault is the severed
hand of Luke Skywalker, which they use to clone the
new version of him, and the lightsaber that fell down in Cloud City.
So in that version of the events, the Emperor sends
agents to acquire those things, so I think the new
trilogy is doing something similar where it's like,
you know, someone who understands what lightsabers
are and how valuable they are and how valuable this
specific lightsaber is, gets their hands on it through
smuggling channels, and just, you know, puts it in a
vault for later because it's like, someone is definitely
gonna come looking for this.
Speaking of clones, next big crazy theory: Rey is secretly
an Anakin clone, and that is why the lightsaber called to
her so powerfully.  And the force is mysterious and
unknowable in this really grand way.  So objects can call
to people that aren't necessarily bound by blood,
so if you're force sensitive, an object that is associated
with the force like a lightsaber or a holocron can still call
out to you.  There are, you know, there are areas like the
cave on Dagobah, which are strong in the dark side of
the force that can also affect you, no matter what your
bloodline is.
But I swear my favorite crazy theory right now, I totally
don't believe it, it's totally crazy, but it's totally amazing,
that Rey is secretly an Anakin clone.
Next big theory: slightly more plausible based on the
events of the movie.  Rey is secretly Luke Skywalker's
daughter, and that is why the lightsaber called out to her
and why Maz Kanata referenced Luke Skywalker and
then, you know, calling out to his father, Anakin Skywalker,
as if she were saying this lightsaber belonged to your
father, and his father before him.  There's also that line
that Mark Hamill re-recorded from Return of the Jedi for
the Star Wars Episode VII trailer, for one of the early
trailers where he says, "The force is strong in my family.
My father has it.  I have it."  And then it just cuts off,
but the rest of the Return of the Jedi line is when he's
speaking to Leia, and he says, "You have it."  So it's like
he's talking to Rey's character saying that she is part of
his family.  Now in the strictest of terms, I hope they
don't answer this question right away because it's kinda
fun to theory craft about, especially if they're going to
mirror some of the story beats and reveals from the
original trilogy, like we didn't learn about Luke and Leia's
relationship 'til Return of the Jedi.  It didn't become
explicit 'til Yoda talked about the other Skywalker, and
then Obi-Wan explained to Luke, "You have a sister,"
and then a lightbulb just turns on over Luke's head, and
he's like, "Oh my God, it's Leia.  Leia's my sister."
My last big theory, and this is a really crazy one: Rey is
secretly the daughter of Supreme Leader Snoke, and
that is part of what's going on with Supreme Leader
Snoke taking Ben.  You know, evil person raises good
character's child to become a dark side force user.
Light side character raises dark side force user's child to
become a good Jedi.  Now as awesome and crazy as
that is, you know, part of the reason why I think that
Snoke isn't directly going after Luke or, you know,
doesn't want Kylo Ren confronting him directly is
because he doesn't want Luke to turn Kylo Ren back to
the light side.  Kylo Ren's still feeling the pull of the light.
Snoke doesn't want him to pull a Darth Vader on Kylo Ren.
"There's still good in you.  I can sense it."
Snoke probably wants to sidestep that entirely.
Well, let me know in the comments, what is your favorite crazy theory about Star Wars Episode VII?
And remember, like the ones that I picked for this list,
they don't necessarily have to be true.
Just let me know about your favorite theory that you've
heard that just sounds absolutely crazy.
What's gonna happen next is, I'm gonna post my
Sherlock special video later tonight.  It's on PBS if you
live in the United States.  Benedict Cumberbatch, Martin Freeman
are amazing.  They're also both part of the Marvel Universe now.
Benedict Cumberbatch is Doctor Strange.  Martin
Freeman is going to be in Captain America: Civil War.
So be sure to check it out.  My video posts later tonight.
While you guys wait for everything to post,
you can click here for my Daredevil season 2 Punisher/Elektra video that I posted last night,
and you can click here to learn all about the Suicide Squad special that's happening on the 19th.
Thank you so much for watching!  Everybody, let's high five.
I'll see you guys tonight.